Well,
you are,
no women had no rights
when Taliban came to Afghanistan.
What you don't know is Afghan women had
their rights before European women even
knew,
but that was in American woman even knew
that,
uh,
a very sophisticated country,
in that sense that women were working
shoulder to shoulder with men and women,
their work,
nightclubs,
women,
no,
there's picture I've seen a my mom and
her friends wearing high boots,
mini skirts,
dancing,
you know,
going to work with the beautiful suits,
above the knee skirt,
high heels.
The country went like 500 years
backwards.
That's the part that was really
extremely upsetting for African women
because if you never seen independence
and freedom and you'd,
it doesn't hit you so hard if somebody
surprises you a little bit further.
But if you had complete freedom and it's
come in and it's all taken from you,
it is a shock that it's extremely
difficult to absorb.
And,
uh,
but it was beyond that for me when I
looked at my country at that time,
we should
ask about how Judas,
but children want
it can make an Amazon mean jail
hall that I watch band wonder.
I'm a probably van neise churches bottom
fishing amita before me.
Then they came back.
Matt [inaudible],
Matt cautious.
Well,
oh no,
no.
Edie formula this,
oh,
as I know by the hundred machine and
Macarthur O'connor and John Button
check,
give a Holler,
uh,
today,
slowly and slowly and Afghanistan,
I mean,
in Cabo I should say.
And this suburbs is still very
difficult,
but in Cabo it's changing a little bit,
but once you go to a shock like that,
a lot of,
um,
uh,
media asked me a lot about,
you know,
well,
are you working on getting the burgers
off their women?
And
my answer to that is the last thing that
an Afghan woman is thinking about right
now is the,
she have a burqa on or off.
She's worried about her life,
about her safety,
about her family's safety.
She's poverty is in the highest level
right now.
She just cares about building a fire,
making some rice and feeding her family.
Uh,
the priority of having her Burka offer
on is not on top of her agenda.
Uh,
what we need to do for women in
Afghanistan is education,
education,
so they can stand up for themselves.
And when I'm in Afghanistan,
I,
I've never worn a burka.
My mother never worn a burka,
neither my grandmother.
So it's not something I've ever seen
before.
I shot the movie,
I made a statement about it.
I just refuse to dress like that.
A,
I want it to be one person has to start,
you know,
be the example of saying it's okay,
oh,
look at me.
Okay.
So I have,
I have a little scarf sometimes was on,
sometimes was off.
I wasn't so paying attention to it,
covering my face and all that all the
time.
And um,
yes,
I got some looks,
but I
didn't care about it.
I just said,
you know,
deal with it.
I'm not going to do it.
May 2nd.
Oh,
what was the school?
It's yes to make
nay nay.
I'm okay.
I could put pushing music.
Mama
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Martha was a
star pass now middle for me,
but goes I should have done buddy exxon.
Yeah,
mathematic model.
Shuba sad.
[inaudible] Mum [inaudible] I'm not a
holiday.